it was my high school prom this was this
dude in my school who knew not to dance
and i could see all the ladies around
them
dancing and i was like i
need to learn how to do that he was
doing that
that move yeah i can't do it as well
anymore because
but he was doing that he was doing that
so some guys go straight tanning bed
oil
ah i did that as a young man i'm older
now i'm attracting a different crowd
the grease that i use
is olive oil
because the ladies who are after me are
generally a little hungrier so i have a
little caloric intake on my body
that they seem to really like look i
know a lot of people like the sun's bad
for you it causes cancer yeah you know
what else causes cancer
everything
do you know what doesn't cause cancer
this penis so i need people closer to it
which means i need a tan and i go
straight outside baby oil and aluminum
foil yeah
skin cancer what
look
my theory is this
you're not going to get skin cancer if
you keep burning your skin off
you're just replacing it i'm like i'm
like a lizard first of all you got to
have the body
look at those moves look you know what i
get a little older so my shoulder hurts
a little bit so i can't shimmy like i
used to you got to be packing a little
bit of heat you know whap
originally that was written about me
white ass penis if you're not packing
what you need to pack there are tricks
of the trade and i just did this for the
interview
right
and i know some people say why did you
pick such a small cucumber
well you want to make it realistic you
don't want to scare anybody away plus
cucumbers
are good for you the thing about packing
at the heat though
if you haven't had a chance to pack your
lunch
i did used to use a roll of quarters
but then
i was dancing for a woman one night
and she got so close
i knocked her teeth out
the quarters i find my clientele
they need a little fiber so every now
and then i can take some celery out take
some cucumber out
dose them and we're back on board like
right now i'm working on the character
the mechanic
now the mechanic maybe the plumber
i can't decide yet but again it fits my
demo the women who i'm dancing for
they don't want to have sex all night
long
they want somebody who can fix their
[ __ ] when it breaks
the plumber you know come let me fix
your pipes oh you got something clogged
in there that one doesn't work as well
if i'm walking down the street and i see
a parking meter
and that parking meter needs to be
ridden
i'm riding that pole i did try to
audition for um thunder down under for a
little while and there's a new magic mic
review i've never really heard back from
anybody
which i
guess is feedback i tried to start my
own dancing group called northern
exposure
24 day i'm living liver just to make it
through another 24.
smoking i'm getting high just to balance
out the lows
and they always tell me that i should be
living better and i suppose but you know
how the story goes
another day another dollar howler 7 p.m
what's it gonna break another bug